my father who's a boomer has been
telling me his generation ruined the
country for years
he's disgusted by what we're dealing
with now but it's
there are some Boomers some people in
that generation who are willing to admit
the failures of that generation the
blame game only goes so far and uh and
there's not a lot that comes of it where
we're just pointing fingers back and
forth a little bit of introspection
would be nice and the thing that and
it's good that your dad can engage in
that what makes it so frustrating is
that very often people in the boomer
generation will um quite enjoy pointing
fingers at the younger generations and
blaming them and talking about how
terrible they are and yet there doesn't
seem to be any moment of pausing where
they go wait a second wait a minute
where did that where did they come from
those are our kids that are acting that
way what we discover is that we are a
fallen race of beings and um none are
perfect